[Música]
qué tan vivos estamos
para certificar que una persona está
muerta físicamente tenemos que verificar
cuatro pasos que su corazón está
latiendo tomarle las pulsaciones que
esté respirando y que sus pupilas
respondan al estímulo de la luz
la luz la responsable de que percibamos
los colores
los seres humanos pasamos alrededor del
90% de nuestra vida dentro de edificios
o sea que pasamos la mayor parte de
nuestra de nuestro tiempo encerrados
dentro de que arquitectura lo hacemos
a través de los sentidos el cerebro
recibe e interpreta toda la información
que viene desde nuestro medio ambiente y
lo transforma en sensaciones y emociones
la calidad de los ambientes están dadas
por la forma las dimensiones las
visuales y la luz dentro de estas
últimas se encuentra una herramienta muy
poderosa el color y que sabemos del
color que nos afecta de una manera
espacial si habrán escuchado pintado de
blanco así parece que el espacio está
más grande
pintada de rojo o sí o no pero esa
parece para esa parte parece que se te
viene
pinta de azul en una habitación parece
que se te achica
es así que la neuro arquitectura estudia
como un entorno físico afecta a nuestro
cerebro e influye en nuestros
comportamientos y nuestras conductas el
color nos afecta de una manera sensitiva
y un ambiente puede hasta causarnos
emociones puede aumentar o disminuir
nuestra creatividad nuestras emociones
generarnos calidez generarnos contención
alegría o la verdad que ganas de irnos
porque los colores transmiten es así que
hasta el día de hoy me pregunto por qué
la mayoría de los hospitales están
pintados de blanco el color más aislante
y frío que existe todo lo contrario lo
que tiene que transmitir un hospital
hospitalidad
y como sabemos lo emocional se
manifiesta en lo físico y un ambiente
puede causarnos aumentamos la
creatividad disminuir nos la
concentración aumentar los ritmos
cardíacos disminuir nuestras pulsaciones
o hasta aumentar o disminuir nuestro
apetito el color es una herramienta de
identificación y expresión con qué color
nos identificamos con qué color nos
expresamos todos los días con ninguno
porque la mayoría de los seres humanos
le tiene miedo al color una de las
razones es por prejuicio si por
prejuicio porque lo del color está
asociado a lo lúdico a lo infantil y de
esa manera los adultos no seríamos
serios porque estamos en una sociedad
donde no se nos permite ni el disfrute
ni el merecimiento otra de las razones
es por mandatos familiares o sociales
siguiendo esos mismos prejuicios porque
hay que pertenecer porque hay que hacer
lo que se debe lo que corresponde porque
hay que ser reconocidos reconocidos por
quién
cuántas cosas dejamos de hacer o hacemos
por los mismos motivos
pero una de las razones más importantes
es que el color no saben vibrar de una
manera diferente si más alta más baja
más intensa de una manera diferente hace
que tengamos esa sesión esa sensación de
miedo de incertidumbre y que lo
rechazamos por las dudas porque claro el
color no es solamente una cualidad de
nuestros sentidos la luz es nuestra
principal fuente de energía y el
espectro de colores proviene de la luz
es así que los colores son energía y el
efecto que causan en nosotros afecta a
nuestro estado bioquímico de una manera
diferente pero entonces o sea el miedo
al color no es hacia el color sino lo
que nos provoca por qué tanta
resistencia porque no nos animamos a
incorporarlo en un cotidiano si es tan
fácil de adquirir porque tanta
resistencia al cambio pareciera que nos
olvidamos de la naturaleza de existir y
nos permitimos estar muertos en vida se
acuerdan de la certificación del
principio
el corazón las pulsaciones la
respiración y el estímulo de la luz
no serías color naranja en qué momento
del día te dan ganas de usar color
violeta porque nos permitimos estar en
una nebulosa gris
qué diferencia hay entre estar muerto
físicamente y estar muertos en vida no
nos permitamos estar en una nebulosa
gris sabe lo que es la nebulosa gris
estar vestidos todo el tiempo de colores
neutros grises beiges nude vivir en una
casa gigante toda pintada de blanco
trabajar en ambientes tóxicos
alimentarnos de procesados vivir en un
medio ambiente contaminado les suena
no les parece que tenemos que
replantearnos nuestras conductas como
ciudadanos un área sana la construimos
entre todos
el color es una herramienta increíble es
un impulso hacia la transformación de un
estado es un refugio del alma y por
sobre todas las cosas nos conecta con
nuestra esencia de ser seres vivos en mi
infancia he tenido muchos momentos
grises y los pude transformar en color a
través del arte y les puedo asegurar que
sé y que siento lo que cada color
produce en mí el color es naturaleza
todos los colores provienen de la
naturaleza y el efecto que causan en
nosotros es exactamente el mismo que el
lugar donde lo compone el color es vida
y nosotros somos color nos certificamos
más ningún tipo de muerte certifiquemos
vida e impulsemos nos hace a la vida
como otra vez estimulando el corazón con
vínculos ordenados y amorosos estando en
acción haciendo lo que nos gusta
disfrutando respirando profundo bien
profundo en áreas sanas respetando el
espacio de cada uno
y por último estimulando nuestras
pupilas haciendo vibrar nuestra piel
dándole mucha fuerza a nuestro corazón
con mucho mucho color vos estás seguro
que estás vivo gracias
[Aplausos]